[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Chris Voss.
And over the next 30 days,
you will learn key negotiation
skills you can use to become
a more confident colleague,
trusted leader, and advance
your professional life.
You're going to practice and use
12 proven negotiation tactics
that I developed as
an FBI negotiator.
The upward inflection helps
harsh things land gently.
When you mirror, it starts
to help you focus more
on the other person.
If you're curious, if
you're actually curious,
it's going to come
out in your voice.
"How am I supposed to
continue working for you
if I'm not getting paid?"
As you progress, the tools
will build on each other.
First, you will learn how
to build trust and rapport
at work.
Then you will learn how to
strengthen your influence
with calibrated
questioning techniques.
Finally, you will learn how
to create epiphanies in order
to get to the agreement
or to get the agreement
to come to you.
During our time together, there
will be interactive practice
scenarios with the community
of other fellow negotiators.
Collaboration
between colleagues,
that's really a negotiation.
And when your intent
is to collaborate
with people for a
better result, then it's
always appropriate to negotiate.
I'm Chris Voss, and
this is MasterClass.